hey I think this emote is going to be
very popular it's found by trading a
homeward bone with pickle P or pumper
rum the crows whose nests are found at
op filing shrine after you buy the tower
key from the handmaiden as always
there's this huge list of shiny items
that you can trade by dropping one at a
time and I'll throw a list of all the
currently known ones in the description
the most notable ones though are Lucca
tiles masks emotes a lightning gem and
the shiniest reward of all while you're
up in the rafters grab that Estes shard
and then walk to the far end and hit the
wall it's an illusionary one there are
so many of these in Dark Souls 3 behind
it is the covetous silver serpent ring
which increases Souls dropped by around
10% number three is that the Estes shard
and nest and the ring all of it is
accessible early without the tower key
via this jumping shortcut off the tree
face the roof run diagonally up the tree
and then do a diagonal right while
pressing l3 if you're having trouble
making the jump don't worry you're
probably not bad it's just more than
likely that it's been patched since this
video came out so no one told me is a
key number four in lothric you would
have met a woman named Emma in the
cathedral if you kill her then it
initiates one of the major endgame boss
fights early which leads to an endgame
area if you can kill the boss and it's a
pretty big if because the dancer is
tough killing her legitimately at around
soul level 35 was by far the hardest
thing I've done in this game and I
finished it a few times now however if
you do it then the rewards are pretty
damn good especially if you're running a
faith or a strength build because there
are a lot of miracles and strength
weapons in upper lothric castle here's a
short list of what you can get
now there is a way to choose the dancer
and kill her easily on any character but
it's probably gonna get patched soon
I'll tell you about it later in this
upcoming video instead number 5 so fast
forwarding to the undead settlement
there's this really secret covenant that
you can join but you have to do it
before killing the cursed great would
turn right at the burning tree go across
the bridge and then go around the right
side of the building through these
barrels climb the ladder and run along
the rooftops to the right below you'll
see a cage carrier but as long as you
haven't killed the cursed great wood
he's non-hostile so walk up behind him
and you know do the logical thing climb
into his cage get thrown down into a pit
crawl out of your cage and talk to ha
Drake to join the mound makers covenant
mound makers drop a white or a red sign
but it appears purple so if someone
summons you with this sign then you can
either kill the enemies in their world
and help them or you can kill the host
or their phantom for the reward
alright so between us here's what we're
gonna do when the game first comes out
no one's going to know what these purple
signs do so put on a white summon ring
that you get from yuria gets summoned
into someone's world and just kill all
the enemies help them out be friendly
wave at them and then once you've gained
their trust turn on them when the time
is right
backstab them when the health is low or
something like that eventually you'll
get 10 vertebra shackles and these can
be handed in for a new katana called
bloodlust which I've heard is good or 30
shackles rewards you with the warmth
spell
number 6 when I first uploaded this
video I said that you had to offer the
young white branch to the Giant in order
to gain his friendship but apparently
this isn't true though boys ish in the
comments said that he doesn't fire upon
you if you start with the white birch
starting gift which I confirmed and
that's at least somewhat interesting
right anyway in this reuploaded video
enjoy the fact that you can do emotes at
the fire keeper
to get a response exciting huh number
seven did you know that some enemies are
ridiculously weak to fire for example
dogs the tree hollows both of those will
rise on the ground if you hit them with
any fire damage at all which pretty much
guarantees you a kill after the first
hit the best example of this though are
those maggot monsters who are completely
incapacitated by fire so pull out the
torch
every time you face against them without
this knowledge of fire they're really
tough because they cover you in maggots
and you're bleed meter will rise for a
ridiculous stretch of time but don't
worry if you do get covered in maggots
simply pull out a torch and they'll all
fly off number eight in Farren's swamp
if you follow the left wall as soon as
you enter the swamp you'll eventually
come across these three tree monsters
and after dealing with the [ __ ] of
the swamp I bet most of you just ignored
them well if you kill them one of them
drops the black bow of Ferris which is
one of the best ranged weapons and also
Faris's cap number nine before Farren's
swamp is the crucifiction woods where
you'll experience your first NPC
invasion from yellow finger if you're in
ember form kill him and he'll drop the
xanthus hell and a hazel pick and this
is a recurring theme throughout the game
so if you're someone who wants to hunt
down every weapon make sure you're em
bird at least once in every area and
you'll get invaded and you'll get NPCs
to kill for their weapons number 10
speaking of killing if you're wondering
what NPCs drop don't worry I sacrificed
one of my characters and made him go on
a murdering spree to find out Henry
drops her luck scaling straight sword
horace drops a shield with really
balanced defenses conics the Pyromancer
gives his awesome looking set Aegon
drops his weapon and his shield arena
drops the tower key the giant drops the
hawk ring sigrid drops the storm ruler
the Pierce shield and the Katarina set
saris drops her talisman yuria
drops dark drift the invisible katana
Leonardo ops his hat
and patches drops his spear and his ring
most of the NPCs I've named just now
also dropped their ashes which gives you
access to a bunch of their armor sets at
the handmaiden if you didn't know and if
you're wondering where to find these
NPCs and initiate all their quest lines
subscribe because I'm going to be
putting out a video this week with all
of that info because the first time I
played Dark Souls 3 I missed so many
quest lines and you should be able to
catch them all with you watch that video
but to finish one more thing which is a
bit of a challenge to you guys I wanted
to put this in as a secret but I
couldn't figure it out so in the undead
settlement past the ladder we climbed
earlier to get to the mound makers
covenant there's this NPC who is a
friendly undead conglomerate another
nine are disappeared so granting carries
a cane he this cage and now it's never
coming back
so coming through the cage and become
Nana's shade I cannot figure out what
this guy is on about and I can't figure
out his purpose do you have any idea my
best guess is that he's giving you a
hint that you're supposed to climb into
the guys cage nearby but oh damn
that's from software's idea of a hint
apparently thank you for watching guys I
hope you learned something new also I
wanted to give a huge shout out to a
Russian souls uploader named will max
he's been doing the Russian captions for
all the recent videos and he was the one
who reminded me to enable that setting
in the first place which allows people
to contribute their own captions so do
me a favor and check out his channel and
since I've enabled it I've had
contributions from people who speak
Portuguese now Chinese contributors and
if you know a language other than
English and you feel like captioning
some videos I'd be so thankful if you
could do that it means I could talk to a
wider audience so yeah I'd appreciate
that and thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one